hello now he has uh created some of the
music for some of the biggest shows on
both the west end
and broadway but now the musician tim
minchin is taking center stage himself
and bringing us his first
studio album something like this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
tim is joining us now hello to you tim a
very good morning to you
hello k how are you i am very well
indeed um tell me about this new album
sounds great
yeah well i'm glad i'm glad it sounds
great that that clips of a song called
the absence of you which is very
hyper romantic and uh not the whole
album is not quite that
un-ironic but um yeah it's it's
definitely a studio record it's
it's a set of 11 songs they're kind of
storytelling songs they're
about love and life and they're
kind of quirky and a bit uh unromantic
romantic like i
often am and people are really
responding to
well and i'm very very happy about that
um apart
together how very apt for 2020 but you
wrote it
before the events of the pandemic didn't
you
yeah i've been i've been you know i
didn't just
sit in a studio for six weeks so it sort
of got built over a couple of years
after we moved back to australia in 2018
and kind of finished it as the pandemic
started
and around that time one of the songs on
the record is called a part together
which is actually
uh one of these romantic unromantic
songs which addresses the uh
the fact that love is is really when
you're in a monogamous relationship
about watching each other fall apart
so it's about falling apart together um
but that
was going to become the title of the
album and then it suddenly
the word apart together became
synonymous with
with sort of covert stuff and the whole
album in fact
has sort of been influenced by the world
we live in now and had a total
different light shone on it it's quite
interesting how it now feels like it
really belongs in this year
you um you say that you've gone back to
australia a couple of years ago did live
in america for quite a long time didn't
you when you look back
uh what's happening in the u.s at the
moment not least with covey but also
because of the election
um what do you see
um look it's such a long conversation
isn't it i think
um i think obviously it goes without
saying
for someone like me i suppose that i
think that president's done
hopefully not irreparable but terrible
deep damage to that country just because
his rhetoric
is so divisive obviously um policy
matters hugely but how how nations talk
about themselves
and talk about their enemies this this
division that we have in britain as well
and in australia
increasing binary ideas of who we are
uh it worries me i think about it all
the time and i am
i'm worried about my friends over there
with what's happening with covert
i'm worried about this election
resolving as it should
um but i'm quite smug that i'm sitting
here in australia by the beach
yeah we talked you talked a little bit
about covid there and it's had a huge
impact of course on the industry um that
you have been involved with
um for so long i'm sure many of our
viewers know that you did a very
successful stage adaptation
of roald dahl's matilda amongst other
things
but it's absolutely decimated the
theater industry certainly here in the
united kingdom
it really has and if i get asked like
everyone does how has
covert affected you and really how it's
affected me
it just doesn't matter compared to how
much
it's affected the people who rely on my
work or work i've contributed to for
their livelihoods so hundreds of people
around the world
make their livings off matilda and other
other things i'm involved in and
it is a desperate time i
understand there are no even your last
guest you know
the balance between trying to advocate
for her trade
and understand that that there's
necessities of i i come i live in a
country where
we have locked down very hard and now
basically has no
we have no virtually no covet in the
country
that's not going to happen in britain
it's a totally different scenario but
um but the theater industry and the arts
i think we have always undervalued what
they contribute not just economically
but what they contribute to it connected
to the trump conversation to our
national identity the stories we tell
ourselves and
i am desperately worried
uh but optimistic just because there's
no other
there's no point in not being i i'm sure
theater
will survive and i just hope some of the
very difficult decisions
your government have to make i hope they
include thinking about the long-term
cultural and economic impact that the
arts has on your country
what impact has covered had on australia
tim what's it been like living through
it
well we've been very lucky and we're
obviously down in victoria i live in new
south wales victoria
so each state is is sort of a region and
is dealing with it in their own way
victoria had an outbreak and this whole
state got shut down
really hard for a really long time like
don't leave your house for three months
apart from a walk with your dog
and uh they went from having hundreds of
cases on the brink of
uncontrolled outbreak to zero cases zero
new cases
zero deaths zero for the last 20 days so
they basically expunged it from there
you know which isn't
again different from britain but we are
a model of what you can do with a with a
discrete population
if you go hard at it which doesn't speak
to the economic
uh suffering that we're gonna continue
to have
but we are just so lucky and we know
we're lucky and our hearts go out to you
guys because
most of my friends are in britain and
i'm talking to them all the time and
it's uh
i i don't think we'll really understand
what this thing did to us
culturally and emotionally and
psychologically until
some years hence and we'll look back and
go ah wow
yeah you know it's hard to uh quantify
isn't it it's why we keep asking each
other these questions
yeah exactly now during the break let's
lighten the mood during the break i
heard you a bit of honky chunk on that
piano i wondered if you might possibly
share 30
seconds of that for our viewers
[Music]
this is how i deal with covert right i
just sit in my
um a room and play the blues
[Music]
[Applause]
honestly i i just when i
i think the fact that i'm a musician
some kind of
miracle anyway because i never thought
i'd be able to make a living out of it
but
in times like this i do music and this
comes back to the question about the
arts it
is i'm so blessed to be able to play but
for all of us this is the stuff we go to
right when we're locked in our houses is
television and stories and music and i
don't know
the romantic in me thinks as long as we
keep
uh you know communication and music and
art alive we'll survive as a
species but for me on a personal level
it's just an escape it's just
something i get to do that i just think
uh it's why i'm so passionate about
music education and
the royal shakespeare company with
matilda's constantly pumping money into
music education and i do a lot of
you know a bit of not enough charity
work with kids and stuff like
for me like for matilda stories are her
escape for me music's my escape
players out with a bit more on the piano
if you would indulges
all right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
two
this is a much better interview i should
do more of this and less of this
[Music]
oh
buy my album out now with all your spare
covert money